hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game between nipple and magnus
in our preparation for the world chess
championship match in dubai this year
this game was also played in the world
chess championship match
in a world championship uh blitz
tournament also in dubai i was played in
2014
and again a very nice game featuring a
jedi mind trick moment so you guys will
enjoy this one uh so let's check it out
it's nipple with the white pieces and he
opens with e4
magnus goes for e5 we have knight to f3
knight to c6 and now d4 never goes for
the scotch opening we have e captures on
d4 and now knight captures on d4 and now
we have bishop to c5 so attacking this
knight twice now usually uh people play
something like bishop to e3 just
defending this knight but now we have
knight captures and c6 and now uh not uh
recapturing or recapturing with the
b-pawn but rather a queen to f6 going
for that
charlie white attack or the throbbing
gambit as it's been called uh so you you
can't really save the knight otherwise
you're getting checkmated you have to
play something here and you could play
some like queen to d2 you could play
queen to f3 those are all very known
moves but nipple goes for f4 and it's a
move that um
he's been known to play uh but uh it's a
very very rare move so how yeah will
black continue well obviously you have
to capture back here and it seems like a
good idea to capture back with the queen
so you don't mess up your pawn structure
but in this particular uh opening where
this line is played it's usually better
to just capture with the pawn so here d
captures on c6 this also allows your
bishop to quickly enter the game if
needed
knight to c3 and now
we have queen to h4 with check
interestingly knight to h6 is considered
best here and there is a game that
nepal played against uh
lazaro baptista bruzon and next year in
2015 in the uh kappa blanca memorial
tournament where nipple won a very nice
game but here magnus goes for queen to h
for check and it is now as of move seven
that this position has never been
reached again uh so g3 nipple blocks the
attack queen back to a7 and now bishop
to d3 and now knight to f6 by magnus
putting more pressure on the e4 pawn so
queen e2 uh if you're wondering why um
sometimes the the squares light up in
red without me actually wanting to it's
some sort of a bug that's been going on
today i have no idea why but probably
it'll go away uh so here queen bishop to
g4 attacking the queen and the queen now
has to move queen to g2 we're still
keeping an eye on the e4 pawn
and now uh magnus just castle's queen
side and now you can see that black has
a very very nice development here both
of his bishops are
slicing
through the entire board uh and the uh
the rook is very nicely placed the the
ottawa can easily come to e8 so what can
you play here bishop to d2 nipple needs
to castle as quickly as possible uh and
now magnus goes knight to d5 since the e
pawn cannot really capture the knight
but there was the very interesting
knight captures an e4 and now it doesn't
really matter what uh you capture with
because either rook t8 or f5 will be
very strong for example bishop captures
we're going to play rook f38 and i'll
push f5 here attack the bishop and well
we've uh won a pawn at least uh but in
the game knights the d5 was played by
magnus and now h3 never wants to get rid
of this bishop from g4 uh so he can
finally castle bishop back to e6 and now
a3 so still waiting with that castle's
move
and now magnus plays bishop to d4 a very
interesting option here was knight the
e3 it looks ugly but for example bishop
captures bishop captures now this bishop
prevents the white king from castling
and if queen f3 attacking this bishop
you can just play bishop to d4 and still
white cannot castle for example if
castles we can just capture here then
capture an a3 check uh white will fall
apart here so maybe uh a very
interesting way of just keeping that
white king in the center of the board
but magnus played bishop to d4 right
away now okay you're putting a lot of
pressure on the c3 square and now nipple
just trades we have knight captures c
captures and now only now we have
castle's queen side and now d captures
on e4 bishop captures attacking this b7
pawn and now c6 so preventing this queen
bishop battery to be operating in full
capacity rook h to e1 now putting a rook
on a nice open file as the queen is
still on e7 uh and now uh queen to c7
magnus could go to queen to f6 to put
pressure on this b2 pawn but uh c3 then
and uh well you you just kick away the
the bishop for example to b6 but it is
an interesting option you free up maybe
the b3 square for the bishop so but we
have to keep in mind that this is a
blitz game so after rook hd one queen to
c7 by magnus and now f5 trying to get to
this bishop uh well to it to a less
active square bishop to d5 and now
bishop to f4 attacking the queen here so
queen to b6 uh putting pressure on the
b2 pawn now you really want to capture
here and now only now nipple plays c3 so
bishop captures an e4 queen captures on
e4 uh and now bishop back to f6
and now uh the the really interesting
part comes the f7 pawn is extremely weak
here and this is what nipple goes for he
plays queen to c4 puts pressure on the
f7 pawn and magnus trades once we have
rook captures on the one rook captures
and the rook to f8 now
again with the red square sorry about
that
but it's a really cool cool moment
because it seems like the f7 pawn is
defended but maybe there's something you
can do about it so feel free to pause
the video here what would you play in
this position how can white still make
progress uh while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
interesting idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
bishop to d6 that's uh that's the the
move that can be played here and we will
discuss why it wasn't played because now
obviously your rook is hanging you have
to move the the rook so here we have
rook to d8 and now if queen captures an
f7 it seems like everything is perfectly
fine what magnus probably saw in you
know as this is a blitz game is queen to
e3 check king to b1 and now bishop to
the bishop to e7 just winning for black
because of course if uh well your your
your bishop is just uh hanging now and
if you move the bishop for example with
captures then you lose the rook on d1
with check and after king a2 we can even
capture on g3 and you don't really have
a way to attack here just came to c7 and
everything is nicely defended black is
just much much better here but probably
what was missed by magnus is that after
bishop to d6 rook to d8 there's this
capture on f7 and now if queen to e3 you
don't play king b1 you play king c2
seems a bit awkward you know keeping
your king in
the center like this but now bishop to
a7 doesn't do anything because there's
no threat of rook captures on d1 the
king just defends this and if queen to
e4 check you can play king the b3 where
your king is nicely defended the queen
controls this diagonal there are no you
know further uh you know checks that are
there are not uh you know crazy checks
uh and
you don't have all that much to worry
about here for example rook d7 attacks
the queen even queen to e6 you can offer
a queen trade here if captures captures
uh rook to d8 and you are up upon you
have a very nice pass pawn on e6 so
maybe this was uh an interesting way of
continuing this but in the game we have
a4 by nipple and now we have h6 by
magnus uh we have king to b1 and now
queen to a5 so going after this f5 pawn
g4 defending it and now magnus goes
bishop to e5 offers a trade of bishops
bishop back to e3 nepal declines and now
a6 so just making some more breeding
room for the king uh bishop to c5 now
putting pressure on the rook here and uh
now rook to d8 offering a rook trade so
rook captures king captures or rather
queen captures i don't know why i
thought the king captured
and only now queen captures an f7 but
it's only a temporary win of a pawn
because here we have a queen to d1 check
by magnus king the a2 and queen captures
an a4 with checks so now if you go back
we probably have a repetition here uh so
instead bishop back to a3 was played and
now bishop to f6 and now we have this
position where the material is
completely equal
and the bishops are of the same color so
there's not a lot you can do about this
position so queen e6 checking the b8
queen to d6 check and of course king
back to c8 we have queenie six check
king to b8 and he was in this position
on move 36 that nipple and magnus agreed
to a draw
as there is nothing more to be done here
but uh very similar to the previous game
that we've shown uh here there really
was the option of just going after this
f7 pawn with bishop to d6 it was pretty
much the only chance anyone got in this
game uh and uh well it seems that in the
previous game magnus trusted nipple uh
on his assessment of the position and
here it was the other way around and you
know the the opportunity to push for
something more uh has vanished
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it we're gonna cover some
more of their encounters before the
actual world championship match 2021 and
i know you guys are always interested in
this here are the standings of the 2014
world blitz championship so here they
are let me just uh improve that a little
bit so magnus won uh first place as you
can see with 17 out of 21 followed by
yanya ponishi uh and hikaru nakamura
with 16 out of 21 followed by lakwang
liam shakhri muhammadiyah of lavon
vishwanathan and ralph mohammed of
gabriel sergician alexander morozevich
peter svidler sergey youdin alexey
krishna
anton korobov alexander grieschuk
eduardo
and so on uh but you can see that it was
a very very intense uh and this was also
dear that magnus won all the titles so
he of course uh defended his world
championship title against anand he won
the world rapid championship and the
world blitz championship i think uh he
won the rapid championship some half a
point uh ahead of uh fabiano carwana and
anand uh i could be wrong but i think
it's it's the case uh so yeah good year
for magnus but as you can see nipple
always following so will he be uh
following or will he be leading in
november uh we will see what happens
uh so that's the game i hope you guys uh
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank jean
francois bond and matthias bollinger
oliver bernicus the hoodie guy and the
wind machine for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of uh their
interesting previous matchups checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else is happening in the chess
world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day